[Music]
what
Hello friends thank you once again for
joining us on this program I'd like to
know this is a program that answers the
questions that you send to us and we are
always delighted to hear from you to
hear where you're writing to us what
type of questions you have and we
certainly appreciate all the information
that you can share with us all the nice
questions that come to us and we have a
lot of questions and we look forward to
answering each one of them don't forget
to write us at TV at samtv .org where
you can send the questions and we will
do our best or very best in responding
to them as soon as we can I am with
Pastor Steven bore what a blessing
Pastor to have you this moment in this
hour to study together and to answer the
questions that a lot of friends have
submitted uh it's a privilege to have
you here Pastor uh thank you you know
this is a great
program not only because we share with
others uh answers to their questions but
it forces us to do research exactly uh
and that's the reason why we do this
program uh deferred in other words we
don't do it live right because you know
when you're doing it live uh someone can
call and uh you know we just kind of
answer off the top of our head right uh
you know what comes to our mind without
much thought really whereas whereas if
you have the questions sent in you do
the research you're going to have a much
better answer right uh than what you can
do on the SP of the moment uh so this is
one of the favorite programs everywhere
I go people say Pastor I love that I'd
like to know program yeah and we've
thought often about maybe uh expanding
it to an hour but we have so much
production going on that it's very
difficult to expand it to an hour but
maybe someday we'll when we have two
Studios we'll be able to do it ex maybe
we have a little more uh yeah people you
know Personnel to help us with the
production and all those things but yeah
it is a blessing to have you Pastor and
how about we you know start the
questions but first if you don't mind
praying as we need to have the word of I
mean pray before we open the word of God
and it's important to do
that Father in heaven we come before
your awesome throne and we come boldly
because we come in the name of Jesus
Amen we realize that our wisdom is so
limited our knowledge is so small yes
Lord and therefore we need to recur to
you because you are all wise all
omniscient you know the end from the
beginning you have the answers to every
single question and so we plead for your
presence through the ministry of the
holy spirit amen Enlighten our minds
open our hearts and Empower us to live
by every word that you have revealed
through your spirit we pray in Jesus
name amen amen amen okay pastor bour we
have a
question uh that comes to us from
someone in
Uganda uh Joshua from Uganda ask us the
following
question and it says he read an article
by Pastor bour entitled Hebrew religion
calendar and he found the following
statement it says according to the Jews
when the sun began to descend from the
Meridian it was the first evening and
when the sun set on the horizon it was
the second evening thus the first
evening will be at noon and the second
evening would be at around 6:00 p.m.
this is what uh he found in the article
D wrote in that in that um title and so
now he says the following however from
LG white State Pioneer site I find this
and it says the Jews reckon two evenings
the form began at the 9th hour of the
natural day or 3:00 in the afternoon and
the latter at the 11th Hour thus the
pasal L was required to be sacrificed
between the evenings which Josephus
tells us the Jews in his time did from
the 9th hour until the 11th
this is uh again handbook for Bible
students page 64 and so the Joseph is as
or Joseph Joshua is telling us that
which view is correct because both
cannot be true and what is the biblical
stand in this that the Jews had two
evenings thank you I I just like to
before you answer Pastor remember that
this quote that he's uh getting from the
L white State Pioneer side is not a
quote from White this is not L white
writing this is just
what they have at at the site sometimes
they have some answers and questions in
that site as well soor if you can give
us and the handbook was published in
1922 right so it's 100 years old MH
um The Exodus 12 and verse 6 has two
main different
interpretations one is the one that we
find here in the
handbook uh the other is the one that I
believe is correct mhm and uh as uh as
we have in the questions according to
the Jews when the sun began to descend
from the Meridian that is from directly
above it was the the first evening and
when the sun set on the horizon it was
the second evening so between the two
evenings would be about 3:00 in the
afternoon right between noon 6:00 around
sunset time right in the middle would be
uh 3:00 in the afternoon now when is it
that Jesus died
around that time Jesus died at the ninth
hour exactly the which is our which are
3:00 in the afternoon um let me give you
one example uh of a commentary that that
has it as I say in the Hebrew uh
festivals uh study notes uh this is uh
jeson faucet and brown commentary and
there are others uh Albert Barnes and
others of the older commentators have
something very similar between the
evenings is a phrase denoting the part
of the day between the declining and the
setting sun or between noon and
sunset so I believe that that is a
better
explanation uh between the two evenings
which is in Exodus 12 verse 6 than um
than the other and uh you know some
versions translate at Twilight yes
Twilight in in in exod Exodus
12:6 um it says here let's see Exodus
12:6 now you shall keep it the Passover
Lamb until the 14th day of the same
month uh then the whole assembly of the
congregation of Israel shall kill it at
Twilight but literally in Hebrew it says
between the two
evenings so Jesus died exactly at 3:00
in the afternoon I believe that that's
the best explanation that we can offer
uh better than the idea that uh you know
you're talking between 3:00 in the
afternoon and 5 yeah yeah and he
actually that's what that and Josephus
is he's quoting what Josephus tells us
that the Jews did in this time which was
from the 9th hour from 3 till till 5
p.m. uh now however Christ as you
mentioned Christ died at the ninth hour
according to you know the record in the
Bible and I believe Jesus did fulfill
prophecy or fulfilled every indication
that we saw in the instructions that the
lord gave to Moses regarding yeah he was
he was crucified actually uh at the at
the third hour exactly at 9: in the
morning which which was for the morning
sacrifice yes and he died at the hour of
the evening sacrifice so I believe that
that is the best interpretation uh the
commentators are not all agreed and when
the commentators are not all agreed and
when Ellen White doesn't measure in then
you know we have to decide based on all
of the evidence what is the best
translation I hope that this question I
to me certainly makes clear I hope that
Joshua can get this question answer in a
satisfactory way uh let's continue with
the next question this is from Jeffrey
who writes us from British
Colombia and this is uh the one in
Canada and he asks the
following I'd like to know what the
Bible says about stewardship ship of our
finances when it comes to living
arrangements outside of our tithes I
think we should allocate the majority of
our money towards doing God's work and
then spending enough on accommodation
that we deem as sufficient and safe for
ourselves and family of course every one
everyone's situation is different and
enough will also look different I am
debt free and renting my question is
should I even concern myself with
putting aside money to one day own a
home or should I continue to Steward the
money towards other people and God's
work I can see the wisdom in having
emergency funds which I do but I feel
that money put towards buying a home may
be better spent on offerings perhaps
mission trips taking care of parents Etc
sometimes I think this idea of having to
own a home is unnecessary when I can
remain debt free which I think will be
helpful as we near the end and and in
the end my Earthly home won't matter by
salvation of my soul another's will
thank you pastors I appreciate all that
you
do okay now um there's one point which
um this individual
mentions U Jeffrey from British
Columbia and that is that he
rents the bottom line is when you rent
you're pouring your money down the whole
mhm because you're still spending the
money that you could put on a mortgage
mhm and with a mortgage you're investing
in a home that can increase in
value and can allow you to have more
funds to share for with the Lord's work
right so uh you know when you're renting
you're still spending a considerable sum
of money in renting yeah so why not use
that money to something and invest it in
buying a house because then you're going
to develop Equity MH and the Lord will
show you when when it's necessary to
sell the house if you want to and then
use the money that has earned interest
because it's the mortgage that's has
earned money absolutely if the market
increases right uh I think that's the
best way to go furthermore our Pioneers
owned homes Ellen White owned the home
up in Elm Haven that you can visit here
in
California um Ellen White consider that
it was it was a good investment to do so
M and uh so you know I I don't think
that God requires us to take uh you know
all our money except for what we need
for food and for rent and to give all of
the money for the projects that are
mentioned here uh offerings mission
trips taking care of parents Etc uh so
that's the way I see it that um buying a
home is uh is an investment it's not an
expense expense it's an investment that
uh in a good Market increases in value
uh and so that's good stewardship I
think absolutely I I think that you
mentioned you want to do things that
will be financially sound and using
God's money wisely as you mention if you
rent for for for years and years years
you're really throwing away money that
could have been used to build equity
build your home or have your own home
and that if the lord requires that to be
given to his work it would have been an
increasing in in value you know um I
think that also is interesting to think
that I mean I I feel very nice that he
feels that God wants him to not have any
affection to the worldly things I mean
that's great as a good thing but uh you
know if you are called by the Lord to
establish or have a family you know you
want them to have a place that is more
more D theirs you know if you rent you
you have to always uh ask permission to
anything you do uh what if you know you
run out of out of or you don't have a
job anymore you know there's a lot of
things that can happen when you rent
you're not really uh building wisely
your the the the the finances the Lord
has given you it's like you're not
making the right decision uh another
thing is God wants us to follow the
leading of his instructions of through
prophecy in regards to where to build a
home where to have a house and she
mentions that God's plan as you
mentioned Pastor is to have a piece of
land in a May perhaps in a rural area
and have our home there so uh you know
it's important if you are able to to
have a your own place especially the
days are approaching when we will be you
know freedoms are going to be taken away
from us uh and you know you're going to
have a place of Refuge where you can
actually grow your own crops and that
kind of thing and so this is is why I
think that as much as I like the idea of
him wanting to be involved and give
money to the work of God I think that
it's important we follow the leading of
the spirit of prophets in regards to
where we are to aim Our Lives to be and
where we should establish ourselves with
the home you know
investing versus um renting there's a
Biblical principle in the parable of the
talents mhm uh in Matthew chap 25 and
verse 27 uh the one who buried his
talent and uh didn't multiply it yes in
an
investment uh said verse 27 uh the
master says so you ought to have
deposited my money with the bankers MH
and at my coming I would have received
back my own with interest so God expects
us more to do investment than spending
according to biblical principles amen
amen I know we need to do be wise and I
believe God if we're sincere God will
send us clear indications what to do I I
I have known people who have lived you
know renting for it a long time and they
are
financially unable to um you know to
have stability because of that fact you
know so I think this is wise that we
follow God's leading if he has questions
you know nothing you know outlandish or
you know extravagant God wants us to
have simple you know homes but
comfortable as well so I think that God
can lead our friend Jeffrey into that
direction and and realize that God does
not required for you to put everything
you have in God's work I mean you know
at least not yet maybe in the future
like you said the Lord will impress you
to sell something but at least you have
made the decision to be a good Steward
and multiply what the Lord has given you
um all right let's continue with the
next question this is an interesting
question and uh it's from a friend uh
Carol from Kenya so she has two
questions the first question is she has
a wedding and uh she would like to know
if dancing at a wedding will be
displeasing to God that's the first
question so we have the question of
dancing and uh the second question is
regards to her hair if if plating her
hair is a problem and uh I I she says
consider I'm a black and Africa my hair
tends to be thick and hard to maintain
washing my hair and coming it every day
takes too much time and stresses me out
I choose to braid my hair for of like I
think my motive is quite clear before
God however I understand sometimes the
motive might be right by the wrong
action please help regards Carl so two
questions one in regards to the way she
uh you know if she's okay to dance at a
wedding it will be this pleasing to God
and the second question is about plating
her
hair well the Adventist Church has
frowned
on
Dancing there are passages in the Bible
that speak about dancing for example at
Hebrew festivals MH uh but uh there's
always a
danger that it will lead to u to other
things besides you know besides that uh
so you know I would not recommend
dancing at a wedding
ceremony uh so basically that that's uh
that's what I think yeah no it is uh you
know I think that dancing the Bible it's
uh very different from the type of
dancing that we tend to do in any event
social or whatever people that dance
usually nowadays is more in a sensual
way you know uh bringing attraction to
to themselves and like you said it can
be a huge stumping block for some other
people you know uh being giving such an
you know example uh if we talk about
putting our lives closer and closer in
harmony with God and really living in a
time where we are to be more holy than
ever before you know that we need to
live more close to the Lord things like
dancing that it's a more of a take more
of a carnal nature if you will uh really
will bring I believe the the Mind away
from God and really bring a a bad
environment to that where interception
because a wedding remember is it's a Act
of God coming two people coming for God
to unite in holy matrimony to say that
they are forever belong to one another
in the fear of God so it's a a powerful
tool to testify of God and what he
considers to be a right thing you know
between a man and a wife and a woman so
um that's I agree with you Pastor I
think that is not something that we
should um be considering in any wedding
the the dancing even though though
nowadays culturally a lot of people
think it's okay to do that or they say
my culture is a tradition to do this or
that God comes before culture and before
any of our you know ideas of what's
right we should go to the word of God
and and I believe that weddings is a
it's a sacred experience you know so we
need to keep that in mind second
question in regards to the hair it's an
interesting question what would you say
um several things H number one uh it
sounds like her motivation is a good
motivation right it's not to exhibit
it's not to show off yeah uh it's a
practical purpose right because she says
I like to know if plating my hair is a
problem considering I am black and
African my hair tends to be uh thick and
hard to maintain right washing my hair
and combing it every day takes too much
time mhm okay and stresses me out out I
choose to braid my hair for ease of like
there's nothing here that says that the
purpose of plating her hair is to
exhibit herself to be attractive uh you
know there's no selfish motives really
right in what she says and um and the
principle we find the principle in the
Bible of uh you know the issue of attire
and dress yeah in 1 Timothy Chapter 2
vers n and 10
mhm uh is the
principle in like manner also that the
women Adorn themselves in modest apparel
with
propriety and
moderation not with braided hair or gold
or perhaps or pearls or costly
clothing but which is proper for women
professing godliness with good works now
it speaks of here plating hair MH but
when we compare uh 1 Peter chapter
3 1 Peter chapter 3 and verse one wives
likewise be submissive to your own
husbands that even if some do not obey
the word they without a word may be won
by the conduct of their wives when they
observe your chased conduct accompanied
by fear do not let your adornment and
then there a word is added to the King
James tradition it says do not do not
let your adornment be merely
outward so the word merely is in italics
which means that it's added by the
translators yeah so it leaves the door
open for outward adornment too yeah so
it says U merely uh outward arranging
the hair wearing gold or putting on fine
apparel now what is the motivation that
you find in verse three it's to exhibit
yourself ex yourself it's to bring glory
to self right um rather let it be the
hidden person of the heart MH with The
Incorruptible beauty of a gentle and
quiet Spirit which is very precious in
the sight of God in other words what is
the motivation for what you do Ellen
White says that the ACT uh is determined
by the motive that produced the act as I
read her question yeah her purpose is
not to uh exhibit herself and bring
glory to herself it has a practical
purpose right and of course the hair of
an of an person in Africa is different
than the hair of a white person here in
the west right and so um I don't see
anything wrong uh biblically speaking
from uh you know braiding um actually um
plating her hair yes and I think that is
because you know she's probably
concerned of that verse right there in 1
Peter 3:3 where it says uh you know PL
in the hair that he's maybe she's
thinking I am transgressing God's word
by plating my hair but ultimately as we
mentioned the context of that verse is
in regards to Bringing attention
adornment uh excessive time spent in
getting you know your hair adorned and
actually she's actually telling by her
experience that this is a way to prevent
her from spending time combing and you
know doing these things so in these
regards if it's the motive it's truly
for uh practical purposes to keep her
hair looking right and not spending so
much time you know in the upkeep of the
hair I think uh like you mentioned
Pastor it makes sense and she needs to
look it in the context now of course the
plating should not be extravagant right
you know the the purpose is not to show
off right uh what what we need to show
off according to this text mhm according
to the text that I read yes is the the
sweet spirit that flows from inside
absolutely to the outside abolutely
that's what really should be attractive
absolutely and I think that this is
where you know we are to be very careful
to sometimes think like we are to just
do things kind of like you know in the
exterior way and yet our hearts not
really being with God uh are not being
adorned with his presence with that
Christlike character with that love that
care for others and we focus so much
more in the external aspects and and
maybe some people who may you know maybe
in her own experience you know who are
the ones telling her you know the Bible
says not to Adorn your hair or not to
play your hair and these kind of things
well are they showing you know
Christlike character loving you know
being being Meek humble happy uh and
sometimes uh you know we focus so much
on the external but not in interor
interior in the inward appearance of the
heart and I think this is where we need
to make an emphasis on you know and only
the person can evaluate what their
intention of the heart is right you know
we can't deceive ourselves yes where say
well you know my purpose is practical
it's not to show off and then we really
are doing it to show off and by the way
this would apply to men as well
absolutely you know the the in in
biblical times it talks about women but
these days men are as vain as women are
you know with their hairo and with their
you know the with their pierced ear you
know with their earring and you know
with bracelets and you know there can be
extravagance on the side of men also
absolutely that doesn't bring glory to
God absolutely Pastor is and you know if
we are seeing this more and more in this
society today young people spending
hours and hours in the uh way to you
know look different friendly or or
appear like their favorite movie star or
their favorite artist whatever it is and
we idolize people and we want to look
like them even the clothes you know I
remember uh hearing from you know young
people who are willing to spend hundreds
of dollars in shoes you know or or or
dress or whatever and you're like how
can you spend so much money on such a
thing just because of what it looks like
or you know what it is in style or in
fashion so just as you mentioned the
idea that the or once in principle is
the adornment has to be from the heart
simple uh you know neat simple attire
but more importantly things that honor
God so if we do things for extravagance
to be show off to appear you know as I
don't know special or important or
looking you know like like you know all
the way to you know like anybody that
can see a poster from a a pop star or
somebody in the in the world this you
know the secular World a celebrity uh
God is not pleased with us imitating
that kind of Lifestyle at all you know
um it's definitely not a way bottom line
is we we should not be sloppy either you
know because uh God wants us to to dress
modestly economically yeah healthfully
MH because there's some clothing that is
so tight Elway has a whole bunch of
principles yes about what we should take
into account uh when we dress and I
would recommend uh you know people to
read for example the section in uh
messages to young people about dress
also the Adventist home has a section on
that to to know what the principles are
that Ellen White presented uh on how to
choose the attire that we're going to
use and the hair as well amen I believe
that God wants us to be an example in
the heart and be a reflection in our
experience amen well may God bless you
thank you once again for allowing us to
join you in this is hour and we look
forward to the next time
[Music]
blessings